how to stop protein urea. Protein urea is when you have protein in your urine. It tends to be
a chronic issue. I wouldn't even say it's a condition because it's typically benign. It's not
usually an issue whatsoever that you need to worry about. If that was my only clinical finding,
didn't have any symptoms, didn't have any other blood work changes, and remember when you look
at blood work, so this would be a urine sample that they would find that. But if you look at blood
work, there are different parameters that you want to look at. So I have a video on this that
details this on our website. So you can find a lot of information on our website, cuttersclinic.com,
if you go to the blog, or well over 1,000 blog posts, most of the videos tied to them be explained
different things. But when you look at blood work, there's a difference between lab ranges and functional
ranges. So you might be normal. Your doctor may have said, everything's normal. I tested your blood,
everything looks normal, everything's good to go, but you're outside of a functional range. So the only
way to know what that is, I suppose you could Google functional ranges, but to find a functional
medical doctor or practitioner like ourselves that can look at your blood from a different perspective.
So if all my blood work was within normal ranges, I had no symptoms, no other signs of issues, no
other objective findings. And my only objective finding was high levels of protein in my urine,
I wouldn't even consider it. There's probably some genetic factor that goes along with it,
but I would look at the big picture so you don't just look at one test. So if that was the only
thing I had going on, I wouldn't be concerned about it.